you've just started your visit to China
first as Chancellor and you talked
earlier on about a reset both a reset in
relations but also you talks about the
possibility that in the face of brexit
if the numbers don't go the way of the
economy then you might have to reset
have a reset on the public finances as
well you explain what you meant by that
our economy has suffered a shock from
the referendum vote it wasn't expected
and as the figures that we've seen today
show that has had an impact on
confidence we will respond to that in
the way that is necessary to support the
economy the Bank of England in the short
term is able to do that through monetary
policy and in the autumn we will have an
opportunity at the Autumn Statement if
necessary to reset fiscal policy to
respond to the data that we will see
over the summer that tells us something
about how the economy is behaving we're
clear that we're going to support the
economy through this period in order to
be able to take advantage of the
opportunities that the referendum
decision delivers us in the medium to
long term but when you say reset what
does that mean because you know
previously George Osborne here it came
here and he said I have a plan are you
saying we just need to kind of change
plans what we've already said that we
are no longer pursuing a budget surplus
in 2019-20 that doesn't make sense
anymore in the light of the new
circumstances but we have to put
something in place exactly what that
framework looks like will depend on the
state of the economy at the time of the
autumn statement and the data that we
see over the next three months or so
will be crucially important in shaping
our response but specifically that PMI
data today a potentially worse than many
people expected well let's be clear the
PMI data is a measure of sentiment it's
not a measure of any hard activity in
the economy and what it tells us is that
people's confidence businesses
confidence has been dented they're not
sure they're in a period of uncertainty
now our job is to try to restore
certainty as much certainty as we can as
quickly as we can
will be partly by progressing our
approach to the European Union and our
discussions with the European Union and
partly by progressing our discussions
with other partners around the world
including Chinese partners about the
ongoing relationship that we will have
with economies beyond Europe into the
future Chancellor thank you very much
indeed thank you